There are a lot of celebrities that do
have these sort of alternate
personalities.
And that's kind of what the metaverse is
offering you as a general populace. You
know, it's like they've kind of done
this with the elite. Now they're like
turning this over to the common person
and you can become multiple people and
have, you know, multiple things.
So, let's talk about the metaverse. Is
it good? Is it bad? Or is it somewhere
in between? Find out on this episode of
LED Live.
Lights exposing darkness.
Everybody, welcome to another episode of
LED Live. We're glad that you can be
with us this Friday. We have a special
guest to talk to us about a question you
guys have been asking about, the
metaverse, virtual reality. And so,
today we have Dr. Tim Riesenberger and
he is going to talk to us about some of
the scientific implications and we're
going to talk about the spiritual
implications of the metaverse. So,
Dr. Riesenberger, what is your
background? Just a little bit for our
audience.
Sure. Sure. I'm an emergency medicine
physician. I trained in medical school
at Loma Linda University. I did my
residency training at Stanford
University. I have a master's in
preventive medicine. I'm board certified
in emergency medicine and I'm a massage
therapist cuz that's what I did before
medicine. So, if we get stressed out,
you know,
Okay. can loosen up the Get the rub
down. I I have a little time after the
show.
All right. Well, a lot of you have been
asking about the metaverse and you know,
people want to know is this good? Is
this bad? And we have a tendency to look
at these things from, you know, a
scientific perspective and a a general
media perspective and and we also want
to know is this good? Is it is it bad?
What should we know if we are going to
enter VR? I remember
I went to Chicago a few years ago and
they had the
I was at a convention for teachers and
there was this Loma Linda University
Hospital was there. They had this VR
setup. And there was a game for kids.
And of course, my son is all into
technology and he wanted to try it. I
was like, "Okay, you can try it out, you
know."
So, he goes in and it was basically
constructing a skeleton, you know, and
it takes like a minute or two, something
like that. And then he's done, you know.
So, like, okay, short period of time. I
did VR once. Kind of freaked me out a
little bit.
The reason it freaked me out, it was a
game. I think it was at my
brother-in-law's and we had he had a
PlayStation or something and I was going
downhill in a sled on the road, you
know, like a like a wheeled sled or
something.
And the the whole point was to avoid the
cars, right? So, you're going downhill.
It's it feels fast. You It's telling
your brain it's fast. You're going and
the whole point is just avoid the cars.
So, you know, you're you're guiding
yourself with your head and stuff. Make
sure you don't hit the cars. And
invariably, what are you going to do? I
mean, it's the first time. You're going
to hit the car. You're going to hit the
car.
The moment that it was that I knew like
I'm going to hit that car. It was the
weirdest feeling cuz it was like, "Oh my
goodness, I'm going to die."
You're waiting for the pain.
You Yeah, you're waiting for It was so
realistic.
Epinephrine. That's what that's called.
So realistic that it it just like
freaked me out a little bit. My son did
the one where he's in a
a shark cage, you know. And you you
know, you're in you're in the ocean and
you know, waiting around and the you
know, eventually the shark comes for you
and he was just like about ready to
throw the thing off because it was so
realistic. And now we're seeing with
metaverse,
this is looking like it's going to
become a multi-billion dollar industry.
I mean, I've even read reports of people
talking about buying real estate in the
metaverse. Think about that. Like
I mean, a lot of the technology that
we're paying attention to right now of
of even just blending gaming technology
with cinematography, they're developing
content now with the forward thinking of
it's going into the metaverse. Yeah. And
so, you know, it's pretty nuts what
they're capable of right now, but I
mean, it's going to get real strange. I
mean, you know, we're not going to be in
Kansas very much longer.
No, no, no. And I think that's true.
Yeah. Like, what's the point of it
though? Like, just having people live
here, but not really here. Like, why
would you buy a house in the metaverse?
Or I've seen people also buy Gucci bags
for thousands of dollars. And I'm like,
in the metaverse, but why?
Yeah, but why would you buy a Bitcoin?
Right? Now look what it's worth. It's
basically what people are willing to pay
for it.
Right. And that makes sense in terms of
cryptocurrency, but it's like
It's a step in that direction.
Yeah.
I've stopped trying to understand this
world after I saw a little FarmVille and
people were dumping thousands of dollars
into it.
Of real money?
Of real money for no apparent reason and
it's like, what are you doing? Like,
what This is just a game, but this is
where we are. Well, if you're willing to
fork out a billion dollars
for Avengers, right? To continue in the
Marvel Universe, Yeah. Wow. how much are
you continuing for the continuity in the
metaverse?
You know what? I've never thought of
that before, but what if all of these
multiverse type things are literally
preparing people to say, "Hey, there's
these alternate" I mean, people are
already thinking that there's alternate
universes out there. And I wonder how
much the media is playing into that, but
it's like all of this is like convenient
together. It's the matrix. It is.
It's the matrix. If they convince you
that that we already live in a
simulation, then what's the difference
if I go in this simulation? It feels
more fun in here. I can be who I want to
be. I can be with who I want to be with.
I have no meaning in the real universe,
but now I have value. I have meaning in
the metaverse. You can be a superstar.
And I think I think
in a weird way, it's like this whole
idea of I can create an avatar, a thing
I can identify with however I want to. I
can be a man. I can be a woman. I can be
a machine. I can be a
alien, whatever. A dog. You know what I
mean? I can see what life is like
through the perspective of that thing.
But there's no consequences to it. I
think we're all the way back to the
Garden of Eden with the tree of
knowledge of good and evil.
And you're not going to really going to
die. It's just this fake fake world or
whatever that that he's created. This is
just like a complicated version of that
first lie. Absolutely. So, for the
concerned parents out there and I'm sure
there's concerned parents. I mean, you
know, those of us that have kids, we're
concerned parents. Go to the hills.
What?
What are the physiological implications
of VR? Well, I think that's pretty clear
that the key with your brain
is
as a man thinketh,
so is he. Right? By beholding we are
become changed. Second Corinthians 3:18.
And that's that's the concept is that
God has hardwired our brain
to say that thinking, right, is very,
very similar to reality. In fact, God
calls it the same thing. It's like you
become what you think about. You become
what you look at. And researchers in
Parma, Italy, the classic sort of study
that was referenced in Magic Kingdom,
one of your videos that I of course grew
up with and enjoyed tremendously. Um
showed that with these monkeys,
unfortunately, one of the researchers
had left a bunch of peanuts out. It
wasn't, you know, completely cleaned up.
And the janitor was there and they left
the electrode on the monkey's brain. And
when the monkey would eat the peanut,
right? Yeah. That was kind of the issue
is that it would fire motor neurons cuz
it's grabbing, right? the peanut. But
the key is is that the janitor actually
heard
the electrode fire when the monkey saw
him clean up the peanut.
So, in other words, they began to
realize that your brain can't
distinguish
between what it's actually doing and
what it's actually seeing. And then they
followed that up with functional MRI.
And they show people these, you know,
facial expressions and they ask you,
"Okay, imitate the facial expressions,
right?" But the same areas of the brain
are pretty much lighting up, right? When
you look at that funny expression or if
you make it. And that's not 100% bad,
right? Because
Sure. if I tell you, "Hey, do a
cartwheel." Well, what's a cartwheel?
Well, let me show you. If I show you how
to do the cartwheel, your brain has to
fire those motor neurons, right? To you
to now be able to replicate that motor
neuron. And I just want to say that
there's nothing bad intrinsically
with watching someone do something so
that you can then imitate them, right?
But the question is really is the media
itself
damaging? Is the actual experience of VR
and the metaverse as we're talking
about, is that intrinsically
damaging or not? And that's really the
question. And when we see with
functional MRI, those areas of your
brain is lighting up, right? You know,
your brain has trouble with
differentiating between seeing something
and doing something. So, that's kind of
the the start, right? So, when you look
at that concept, is what do you want
your kids to be doing? Right. That's
really the question. And if you want
your kids to be doing something
positive, perhaps it can be helpful,
right? There was a study that just came
out this year on soccer players with
chronic low back pain, right? And they
randomized them into three groups.
Control group, right? Nothing, right? If
you do no therapy, obviously you're not
going to get better, right?
Right. Uh versus traditional, you see
the physical therapy, they go through
the exercise, they give you a sheet of
exercise, send you home, and you don't
do those exercises until you come back
to the physical therapist again, right?
That's unfortunately the level of
compliance is very poor. But, what they
tried to do is they said, "Okay,
we're going to do a VR therapist.
And these are your sessions, and you
know, are you going to interact with the
VR person? Well, of course you are,
right? Because they've shown that the
mirror, you know, just a 3D mirror
increases compliance for people doing
exercise. And this study showed that at
4 weeks and then at 6 months that VR was
superior to reality. Wow. And so that's
the thing is that can this be used to
get your kids to exercise? Well, sure,
if the Nintendo Wii can get your kids to
exercise, probably the VR can get them
to exercise even more. Because the
number one reason why people continue
exercising
is doing it with someone else. Right.
And if you feel you're doing it with
someone else, right? And remember your
brain has trouble differentiating just
with 2D or 3D, right? Seeing versus
doing. Now, this is surround sound,
right? This is actually puffs of air.
You're hiking on the top of Everest.
Yeah, exactly. Pressure suits now. So,
will your kid be more compliant with
exercise in VR? Probably.
But the But the question is, how is this
going to affect them? Go ahead.
So, I remember when we did the
documentary Suitology that was really
just trying to get to the bottom of
like, is the television affecting you?
Yes. Um one of the doctors that we who
was a neurologist in um actually a
neurologist that dealt with psychology
um in
um Los Angeles area. And uh he had
specifically um worked with VR to to
help patients that had been through war.
And there was these real crazy like, you
know, post-traumatic Yeah, PTSD and
really these really psychological
problems that that they were trying to
um get to the bottom of and resolve. And
one way that they would do it was
through the use of VR. They would put
the people back in a war setting.
Sure. They gave them a fake gun, rubber
gun, and then they all of a sudden had
all these people dying all around them,
and then they'd walk them through that
process, and that was somehow
Desensitization. Yeah, something helping
them through that.
Sure. And that always struck me as like
strange. Like, you know, if you have all
this like fear of that experience, why
would you want to go back to that
experience? And it was for exactly what
you said. That process of being there
enough times desensitized you to the
point where you could then manage and
and and live a normal life. And they
could help you through that process. So,
it's like, if you're watching all this
crazy sinful stuff, you know, I mean, is
that basically, you know, inching you
closer to acceptance of that activity or
whatever, you know? Fortnite. If you're
running around playing Fortnite all day
long, you know. Well, sure, and and I
think that your concept is very valid.
Because what they've found in studies as
far as how does VR affect the brain, how
does VR affect memories like a traumatic
memory or whatever, what they found is
they use different types of media
to embed a memory in children to
basically create reality in your kids'
mind. The the 4-to-6-year-olds,
they were able to fool them with the
same success by using audio clues,
taking a picture where they photoshopped
them. "Hey, this is you sing swimming
with orcas. You remember that?" Right?
And then they gave them the VR
experience to try to embed the memory.
Now, the 4-to-6-year-olds,
they'll say anything.
It was so cool. no different. It was no
different. Now, the 7-to-approximately
12-year-olds, like the elementary
school-age kids, they found that VR was
highly successful
in embedding a false memory Oh, wow.
into them. So, again,
That's fascinating. they can use VR on
your kids, and your kids are so
impressionable. It's like, I always tell
people, when you're young, your brain is
plastic, Mhm. basically. And that's I
mean, there's huge implications for
that. Like, for us as guys who aren't
married, um
or uh those of you maybe who are
married, you know, maybe that's an
implication. But the concept is is that
if you marry
and you're younger, you have a higher
risk of divorce. Like at at basically,
if you're a teenager, it's 90%. Wow. But
as you go over time, if it's first-time
marriages, by the way. If you divorce
once, it's always easier to do again,
right? And that's the concept with sin,
right? It's easy to do it over and over
again once you've kind of opened
Pandora's Box, so to speak. But they
found that it was like mid-20s to late
20s. And they're like, "Well, why is
that?" And then the research kind of
caught up and said, "Well, your neurons
don't finish myelinating until late 20s
for guys. Girls are sooner, obviously.
You guys mature sooner as far as brain
anatomy and physiology." And so, the
earlier you're going at uh these
individuals, right? When you're looking
at a 4-to-6-year-old,
it's hard for them to distinguish
fantasy from reality, and we know that,
right? They have imaginary friends,
right? They talk to them. But the thing
is, they grow out of that, right? And do
you have like uh is your
7-10-11-12-year-old
still talking to their imaginary friend?
I hope not, right? But if they're four,
that's probably a normal behavior,
right? But the problem is is that when
you're 7 or 8 9 10 11 12, and with VR,
we can plant now memories, and those
kids said it was a real memory.
Wow. And they said, "Remember when you
were doing this?" And they would
Photoshop their Cuz they can actually
put you like we Mikey and I were viewing
this video, they put the lady on the
other side of the screen in the video
with her reflection. They can do that
now and create an avatar of you. But
now, with Photoshop and even voice
clips, you can you can have the kids say
something.
I think another thing that's really
alarming, you're bringing up some kind
of some a lot of things here, but the
the the idea of like other people being
able to enter into this universe
simultaneously together, right? You're
worried about who your kids playing with
already. Like, what house are you going
over to and all that, right? Now you're
talking about putting that child in a
totally unique environment where other
people could have access to that
endlessly.
I think this is a recipe for disaster.
You think about, you know, if you can be
whatever you want to be. Let's say, you
know, your 8-year-old wants to be 16.
You know, your 8-year-old wants to be
24. And people are going to treat them
like their avatar. appear to be in the
metaverse. And they look like they're
person who doesn't know that. You know
what I mean? They're going to start
approaching them as that age. Wow.
I mean, I just I I just think that this
is not this is not good.
implications.
Or you need controls.
And I think that that's really the
question is, where are the ethics? Mhm.
Uh another study at Stanford out of my
alma mater, um they looked at impulse
control in children.
And they used a great study design,
right? They used Grover, right? Super
Grover, right? And Super Grover was
paying playing Simon Says with them. And
we had just the same clip, right? We
created a VR clip of Super Grover
playing it versus, you know, a 2D
television screen for Super Grover. And
the key was is that on the screen, they
were much better able with impulse
control. But once you created a VR
Grover, they lost the impulse control.
And the implications there are, of
course, economic, right? The concept is
is that I want to remove your impulse
control
when you're wanting to spend, Mhm.
right? We can do that in tangible ways,
right? If you actually have to do
something to go beyond your inhibitions,
then it's harder. That's why the Bible
says, "Make not provision for the flesh
to fulfill the lust thereof," right? You
get rid of your cigarettes. You cut your
internet connection home. Maybe just
access the internet for a while in the
library. Yeah, go to the bar. Yeah,
don't go to the bar. You get rid of all
your credit cards and pay everything
with cash. Because the act They found
that the act of reaching in your pocket
hurts. Hurts, yeah. And to do that is
can be bypassed with a credit card a
little bit easier.
Interesting. And the thing is is that if
we've already seen that children lose
impulse control Yeah. when you create a
VR situation of the identical situation,
what are the implications there? I think
it's very clear. I think you're going to
have impulse control issues in the
metaverse. So, are there are you aware
of any studies about impulse control in
childhood? Let's say, Absolutely.
they they have
The marshmallow. That's the classic one.
Yeah, the marshmallow one. But where
they really didn't have any checks and
balances when they were young,
have those children been followed over
time Sure. as adults, and then how did
they Yeah, I think I think the
marshmallow study is a good one. Uh and
I don't know exactly if it was nurture
versus nature. Were they seeing the
problems at home for the first time
during the marshmallow study? But
essentially, the marshmallow study, and
there's various permutations of it, is
here's a marshmallow.
Not to say that you're the child, but
you're just
at my convenient left hand here. Here's
a marshmallow.
Now, if you wait till I come back, I'll
give you two.
And they just started the clock. How
long could the child resist the
marshmallow? Interesting. And the
concept was is that some kids were able
to go huge amounts of time. But many
kids were like,
Man. As soon as the researcher went out
the room, they ate the marshmallow. And
they found that that was implicated not
just in academic success and financial
success, level of education, marital
success, jail time. Mhm. So, ultimately,
our ability
to resist following our heart is
actually the trigger for success, not
following our heart. Like you guys show
in your clips, I love that basically uh
kaleidoscope clip where you show all of
the instances where Disney says that.
And it's like every single show, every
single movie that comes up. So,
ultimately, yes, it's very clear that
the more you can delay gratification,
the more you can put a lid on the
impulse control, you're successful in
all areas of life. Because, ultimately,
right, we have a fallen nature. I I
notice this in my children when they eat
food. Um my daughter has always been
she'll take a look at the plate and
she'll figure out which thing she likes
the most. And it goes pushes off to the
side and I mean it will like literally
systematically eat around that thing
until it's like the very last thing. And
it like my son's just straight like,
"Cake."
Exactly. You know, it's like he then
he's full, too full to eat the salad or
whatever, right? You know.
He's learned delayed gratification at an
early age. But my wife and I have
noticed this in our children and we have
encouraged, you know, like this behavior
in my son and he's actually transformed
and changed. Now he is actually leaving
the the things he what desires the most
for the last. He'll eat all his
vegetables and salad and stuff like that
first and
it's great. And that's it. And that's
And that's the concept is that we always
have had traditionally because of,
honestly, um
we have a Puritan work ethic. Many of us
are related to the people that came
over, right? They found that what is it?
80% of the US is actually immigrants.
So, most of us here now can trace our
roots back to somebody who came over
here from some other country. So,
genetically, we have that Quaker, we
have that Puritan work ethic and really
that's what has made made America great,
right? Is that people can trust American
quality. People can trust when you say
you're going to pay this back, yes, I'll
pay it back. I don't know if how we're
going to pay back what is 30 33 30
trillion now, but that's more than Maybe
the metaverse will help us make that
back, right?
And that's right. So, that's that's the
concept is that you traditionally,
genetically, have the desire to uh work
first, play later.
Right? But if your job is in the
metaverse, Mhm.
Yeah. right, then that becomes very
blurred, doesn't it? And that's the
whole concept is that even with the
phones, I think we can all attest,
right?
Hard to put it down. Yeah, exactly.
Well, hey, I'm on the phone and oh, I've
got this message or whatever. Oh, I went
to do research last night when we when
we picked up our phones, right? We can
all attest to the fact that it's hard to
stay on task when you have that phone.
Even if you turn all the banners off,
even if you do whatever. Oh, maybe I'll
check that email or whatever. You get
distracted very easily, right? And
that's the concept is that there's
already health implications
for screen time of any Yeah. media,
right? You know, and and there's all
cause mortality studies on that already.
You know, so is VR going to be even more
distracting for you? Cuz it's like if
you're trying to do your job and someone
can interact with you on the metaverse
instead of sending you a notification,
they can walk by and say, "Hey,
what about this? Would you like to buy
this?" No, no, I don't want to buy that.
So, if you have to actually wave that
person away now rather than just turn
them off,
right? Is that going to be hard?
imagine advertising like if you can't
block advertising?
The Geico Gecko comes by like wants to
sell you on insurance. He's like at your
front door. That makes me wonder
what matters to us a lot is like
physical contact with other people. So,
how do you think the metaverse is going
to affect that? Like it sounds like it's
going to breed a lot of dissatisfaction
and probably increase depression. Or can
virtual reality actually give you a
sense that you are in close contact with
someone? Well, a lot of people have
asked me um why I mean and Scotty can
tell you this, I'm a big hug guy. I'm a
big hugger. People don't like that
necessarily. And Small bubble. Yeah,
exactly. Most people like, "Okay." Or
they'll do the like
you know, whatever the side or what what
not. But they've actually shown
in real studies that this close
proximity that you have is so powerful,
not just for the people involved, but I
mean your health, your well-being, your
development. I mean, you have mice
studies, right? And now they've
replicated that on orphan sort of
studies. Is mice when they're born, what
does the mother immediately start doing
to them, do you think? Licking them,
right? But they actually have simulated
everything with that lick. They created
a little brush that was exactly the
same. They all died.
There is a difference between a virtual
touch
and a real touch. There's a vast
difference and then they repeated that
in orphans, right? They were given this
mechanical sort of touch, the same
thing. They simulated a hug, they
simulated the vertical motion that kids
all love cuz of the womb, everything.
They they they tried to like do all of
that and they didn't thrive. Yeah. There
is something that goes on when you have
a real embrace. And that's why I tell
people is I'm actually just being
selfish. I'm actually just drawing that
power cuz I'm working on a an age
reversal program right now.
And I know I'm the oldest person in this
room already. But that's the thing is
grow up on Magic Kingdom?
But could you have age reversal if you
grew up on Magic Kingdom? I said I grew
up on the Magic Kingdom documentary.
That's the thing cuz there's a
difference
I think uh like we talk about is the
media itself bad. And we all know that
the screen takes you from beta wave to
alpha almost immediately. In fact, the
more you do it like the first time you
watch the screen, it takes a little
while, but the second time, your your
your brain waves are in alpha like
within seconds.
And so, we understand that the media
itself, yes, uh does that. But the thing
is when I'm watching Magic Kingdom, I'm
actively engaging. It's like, "Oh, wow,
I never saw that. I know Oh, wow, that's
wrong." Right? And so, when you're in
alpha, things tend to enter into your
subconscious and embed a lot easier. But
when you're in beta like with Scotty and
Tommy pointing out like, "Hey,
do you know the scene in Fight Club
where they talk against God?" I had no
idea they do that. So, immediately, I'm
going to go look at it and I'm like, "I
had no idea they said this." Even though
it's a long
sort of like scene, right? But it's just
going into the subconscious. But when
you're in beta,
when you're critically analyzing
something,
totally different ball game with your
brain. Like And cuz it comes into
motive, right? Why did you go through
those scenes? It's not to like enjoy
Fight Club again, but to say, "You know
what?
How dare they talk about my God that
way?"
You know, and what are the implications
if Brad Pitt just tells me we're God's
unwanted children.
You had You had a question? Yeah. Oh, I
have two. My first one.
So, um Save your questions. You're
building them up. So,
if So, cuz I know a lot of people try to
justify watching movies cuz they say you
have to be careful with um
um when you're in that hypnot hypnotic
phase. Like where you're just staring at
the screen, you can't hear what's going
on around you. You're alpha alpha brain
waving.
Right. So, Massage does the same thing
though.
There's lots of things like when you're
on um on the road and you're listening
to music and you're zoning out or
someone's talking to you and you're
like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh,
I I just missed my exit." Right? So,
that's also alpha brain waving, you
know. So, there's lots of ways you can
go into alpha. It's just a relaxed
state, but you become highly
suggestible. That's my point. So, is it
possible like let's say you want to
justify watching this movie cuz you're
saying, "You know what? I want to go in
and analyze it." Is it
compared to watching a documentary
-mentary, if you're watching like
Transformers, for example, is it easier
for you to go in with that motive and
stay in your What is it? Beta?
Thinking. Your thinking uh your to be
able to think through or will you easily
slip into the alpha wave? It's it's hard
to answer that and I think really Scotty
might have the best answer. And I
remember you were looking at anime at
one point and someone said, "Absolutely
do not watch the Death Note. Let me just
tell you what it's about." Because the
thing is is that think about what is
different in a documentary
versus an actual
Hollywood made movie. And you guys know
this having been in Hollywood,
everything in Hollywood
is down to the T.
Like I remember you guys saying, "That
little thing in the background, that's
not an accident. The color of that is
not an accident. The name of that person
is not an accident. The music playing,
did you know the music playing in the
background will get not only your
emotions, but your hormones in line for
what's coming?"
It's it's absolutely everything is done
exactly
on Q. There's nothing accidental.
Whereas the documentary, right? We're
not We don't have music playing during
our interview, right? I mean, we have
stuff at the beginning at the end,
right? But everything in the background
wasn't designed for creating that mood,
creating that emotion. And that's really
what they're wanting to do is create an
emotion, right? Because they know that
that's 50%
of your character because thoughts and
feelings combined make up the moral
character. And we ignore the role of
feelings, right? We try to stuff for and
resist our feelings. No, create positive
feelings with God. You know, when you
look at
the admonition, it's righteousness, joy,
and peace in the Holy Ghost. How many of
those things are emotions? Two out of
three, right? Our emotions. So, I think
that we forget
that these movies are trying to create a
certain not only message in your mind,
but they're trying to create an emotion
in your mind. And the thing is, what
what I often do, like when I'm looking
at something, like I think I can't
remember who it was, but Steve Chang,
you know Steve Chang, he's a dentist. He
did a post on Alita: Battle Angel. You
know what I mean? And let me just say
it's 100% false gospel. Alita is Satan,
the big guy who rules in the city sky
above. Who is that? Well, you know. And
and the the the the city's name is
Zalem, but the real name is Jerusalem.
Come on. I mean, it's like it's so
obvious. You It's so obvious. Right?
Every But every show, you guys pointed
out, every sort of superhero movie,
the big bad guy is always the god
figure.
Constantly. So, they're they're trying
to create not only information in your
head, but they're trying to create a
narrative. So, just what I recommend, if
people have to do something like Scotty,
and I don't know if you've done this, is
I will turn on the subtitles and turn
off the volume.
So, I don't get any music. I don't get
any like surround sound or what do you I
just get the text of what they're
saying, and I can see some of the
visual. That's an interesting thing. I
haven't tried that one. My wife will
watch things with a with the subtitles,
and so she can definitely hear and read
and think about what's being said and
and stuff like that and but that's it
that's interesting to just totally shut
it off and just listen to that, cuz I I
have turned the music off, and it's like
it's not even interesting, you know?
It's like you kind of just like look at
it and you're like, this is whatever.
But you turn the music on, you're all
wrapped up into it. Cuz your emotion.
What I what I would say to you, um, is I
think there's there's there's
media is so complex, and the way that we
approach the media is very complex. Um,
and and what I what I think that is is
sort of going back to the metaverse
thing, I think the more that you put
yourself in front of that, the more
desensitized you get to those types of
messages.
So, if you are are just saying, "Well,
I'm going to watch this. I'm going to
try to find out everything that's wrong
with it." You know, you you watch The
Matrix and Transformers and all this
kind of gnostic stuff all the time,
it's interesting to see how less and
less you'll be able to actually really
point those things out. Um, I think it's
by not watching them that your
sensitivity actually goes up, and when
you see things that are awry or off,
then you're kind of like, you know, no.
That's not right. And and you get kind
of wrapped up into the storyline the
more that you engage in. I think some
people go into it with a, you know, I I
want to watch this because I want to
know what they're doing, and I'm going
to watch the whole thing, and I think I
just think enough of that over time is
going to desensitize you. And that's the
key is that
a lot of people make the accusation,
"Well, how can you guys comment on this?
You haven't even watched it." Sort of
thing like that. But that's the whole
concept. Do you do you have to say that
murder is wrong
by not experiencing murder? Do you have
to say, "Well, you know, we finally
decided pornography is bad cuz we
watched all of the films." I mean, do
you really have to do that? I mean, you
just present that to someone, and
they'll finally see, "Okay, I can see
how it can affect you." And I'll just
give you a a classic example of what
Scotty's saying is that I had a friend
of mine,
his kids were 6 and 8, and they had
never ever seen a screen of any kind.
Unbelievable. Unbelievable, right? Like
I'm trying to tell people, "Listen,
France is is moving towards age 6 and
below is illegal of screen of every
kind." I have colleagues who are child
psychiatrists. They won't make a
diagnosis of ADD or ADHD or any
psychiatric diagnosis until there's no
screen time for 6 months. I had one
parent say, "That's impossible. How can
I prevent them from seeing a screen?"
That's what our world has become.
Right? And so, that's that's the issue
is that, you know, what what Scotty's
saying is that, you know, how can you
say this if you haven't actually
experienced it or or or done this, that,
or or the other thing, right? But that's
the concept. You're getting
desensitized.
Right? You guys even pointed out in
Magic Kingdom is the way they introduce
the LGBT what QIA A I don't even know
what the letter is now. But Mulan,
right? You pointed out, they did it as
laughing at it first.
And your granddaughter was a
cross-dresser, hahaha. And they kind of
they said contempt, right? First it's
contempt, then it's normal, then it's
embraced, right? So, they're slowly
desensitizing you
uh to that sort of concept. But when you
have somebody who has no exposure, you
see what the real response should be.
And basically, these kids had no No
screens, and so he thought, "Well, let
me introduce them to,
you know, something positive from
media." And what would you say the most
positive thing for media for kids might
be? What would the first thing What kind
of show would you show them? Yeah, like
a nature show. Of course you're going to
do that. So, he did that. He showed them
a nature show.
And when they got to the gazelle
scene
that was caught by the lion, they
started screaming.
They started with cuz they had never
seen actually death, right? I mean, a
6-year-old, 8-year-old probably isn't
going to see an animal killed. I mean,
probably haven't seen maybe a dog gets
hit if they're in the city, but have you
seen a gazelle attacked and pulled down
in the Serengeti
by a lion. They started screaming, "Turn
it off. Turn it off. Turn it off. Why
are you showing this to us?"
Versus you and I can turn on the news
and say, "Yeah, a 14-year-old was raped
yesterday." or whatever. And we're like,
"Oh, really? I'll pray for them." And
then move on. And I'm just like, you
should say, "What? No. Why are you
showing this to me?" Right? Cuz the
problem is is that you and I, like
Scotty pointed out, or we're so
desensitized, it doesn't even elicit a
response. But when Adam and Eve mourned
more deeply
for the first falling leaf
and for their dead, you realize how
desensitized we are. Would you mourn
over fallen leaves?
I think it's beautiful. Yeah, because
because you are desensitized. Like your
world is sin.
But when you come from a world that is
not sin, they mourned. Like can you
imagine? Have you seen somebody mourning
at a funeral? I've seen some serious
mourning. It says they mourned worse for
that leaf
that fell than men now mourn for their
dead. And that's the thing is that
Scotty is spot on. Is you cannot allow
yourself to be desensitized because by
beholding
you become changed. You become changed.
Yeah. I just
Going back to the metaverse, um,
I read a couple articles, one from
Cambridge and one from Oxford, and they
had started to do studies on people that
had severe phobias.
And, um, one way that they would get
people over that phobia was to literally
put them in a virtual world. So, if you
had a fear of spiders, some people have
a fear of getting on an elevator, some
people have a fear of heights. Whatever
that fear is, Let's give you VR
arachnophobia.
They would they would literally give you
VR, and it only took 1/2 hour to get you
over that fear. Half hour of being in
That That's what the article said. Half
hour of of time they could walk you
through it and and basically overcome
it. I believe what you're saying. I'm
just saying to put myself in a VR
situation with there's a bunch of
spiders. No, absolutely not. I would
to take longer than half an hour. I'm
just using that as an exam because
example because that's a common
uh fear. But I mean, I think I think
that is a perhaps viable
use of it, and so I don't want us to get
away from saying okay, all VR is equal,
right? I think physical therapy, getting
people to comply with exercise, perhaps,
you know, desensitization with cognitive
behavioral therapy,
you know, getting over phobias, et
cetera, you know, cuz those traumas are
real, right? Like it's it's it's I think
I think there's a positive use to it.
Like with all technology, there's an
ability to share the gospel around the
world with media, what we're doing right
now, right? So, I think that there is a
positive use to, um, this VR technology
to really help somebody who has
struggled in those areas. But also, what
that tells me is that it's powerful, and
it's very impactful. And if you have a
natural fear, like the Bible says, "I
will put enmity between the your seed
and thy seed." you know? And and God has
instilled in man a natural fear or or
aversion.
Aversion is a better word, uh to sin.
But it's like all of a sudden, if if
you're sitting in this virtual world,
and you're being desensitized to it,
we're breaking you down, now you don't
have that fear towards that sin anymore.
Now you're actually going to start to
enjoy it. Now you're going to start to
partake in it, and it just crumbles down
from there. So, that brings up a very
good question though. If everything is
going metaverse, should the Christian be
like, "No, stay away from that." or
should we be like, "Well, how are we
going to use that to our advantage?" No,
the little lights already got a channel
in the metaverse. That's right.
I mean, imagine like you can build like
the you can see the statue of
Nebuchadnezzar in virtual reality, and
it's showing you like these are the
kingdoms. If you don't like
What I was thinking about was, what
about all these people that don't have
access to
the gospel because their government or
whatever is, you know, takes a heavy
hand toward that kind of thing, and they
wind up in the metaverse. Can you go and
witness to them or preach to them or
tell them about Jesus, and they become
converted? I mean, you would think that
would be a good use of something like
that. You know, I'm thinking
specifically of countries like China. Or
are they going to have a way to block
that? They have a way to block it. You
have to start talking in code or
something. Censorship.
I think ultimately it comes down to
this. Um
we know that it's very powerful. We know
that you lose impulse control. Right? We
know that just the medium itself, like
when I picked up the cell phone and we
had that buzzing, right? Why was there
going to be buzzing?
Cuz this thing throws off radiation. And
do you guys remember what World Health
Organization said about this a little
while ago? Yeah. Use your headset.
carcinogenic. And now now not is this
going to be near me, I'm going to be a
Bluetooth antenna with the screen in
front of me now for who knows how long
a day, right? Yeah, it could be your
job.
Yeah, this is already carcinogenic. We
know that, right? And so what are going
to be the implications now? So I I think
it comes down to
not only
is the media itself damaging to your
health? Yes, it is.
Yes, it is. They they found that screen
time even greater than 2 hours increases
the risk of high blood pressure in 2 to
10-year-olds.
What? But how can I know it's crazy, but
how can you combat that? They found
well, if that kid, same kid, had an hour
of physical activity a day, they could,
you know, try to resist the negative
effects, but ultimately
would you want someone to accept the
gospel if you knew that their
inhibitions were down? If you knew that
their impulse control was down, right?
It's just like what I tell people in my
lectures on the frontal lobe, you know,
I say dementia is a frontal lobe
inhibitor, traumatic brain injury,
alcohol is a frontal lobe inhibitor,
right? And then
I examine the concept of susceptibility.
When you have weakened frontal lobe, you
can be suggested to do something and
hey, why don't you read your Bible? Hey,
why don't you buy Steps to Christ? Hey,
why don't you buy every one of our DVDs
right now,
right? Would it be good for them to have
your DVDs? Sure. Well, sure they would.
But would you sell it to somebody who
was intoxicated?
Yes? I say yeah. Well, no, notice how
there was a little delay there.
Well, no, there
there was a delay there, right? You
weren't exactly comfortable with that.
And the reason why you're not
comfortable with that is the same
concept as when I had an atheist in the
audience, he asked me this question. He
said, "If you believe
that you're more suggestible, you know,
when you're under the influence or
whatever these frontal lobe inhibitors
are, and you believe that there's angels
and demons out there." He was actually
kind of mocking me. He's like, "Well,
why doesn't somebody listen to the good
angel and go rescue a kitten while
they're intoxicated? Why don't they go,
you know, preach a sermon while they're
intoxicated? Why don't they go do
something positive while they're
intoxicated?" And I said, "Because it
comes down to informed consent."
God not only wants you to give full and
free consent, but he wants you to be in
your right mind when you're doing it. If
that makes sense. And and if you're at
the door, you know, knocking on the
door, "Hey,
hey, I want to sell you these religious
books or religious videos. Oh, sure,
I'll buy the whole thing, honey." Right?
Would you really accept that? You know,
if someone was intoxicated, you
wouldn't. And that's the concept is that
the good angels cannot violate your
will.
I mean, they're they're going to be
resistant to that unless God says, "Hey,
specifically go for it, you know." Cuz
God understands the end from the
beginning. But as a general rule, right?
They're not going to use any compelling
force unless it's to protect others.
Like with Balaam, they violated Balaam's
will and caused him to say, "I'm going
to Well, actually I'm going to bless
you." Right? And just like God just took
over the mind or something like that for
a minute, right? But that was to protect
Israel, right? But if the concept is
that you feel a little comfortable and
you notice that with the hesitancy in
our in our group. We weren't exactly
completely comfortable with someone who
had maybe a frontal lobe inhibition,
maybe an impulse control thing, would
you want them to accept the gospel as an
impulse buy?
I don't think you would.
You want them in their right mind to
make that decision.
the health message, right? We get people
and that's my whole concept. I'm working
on this age reversal program, but it's
so that your mind is crystal clear,
right? Cuz when you have a healthy,
strong, powerful body,
you also will have a healthy, strong,
and powerful mind and also a healthy,
strong, and powerful shoulder. They're
not directly correlated, but we know
that we're connected, right? And that's
the concept is that you want that person
in the metaverse
to be 100% sure, to be completely in
their right mind, no impulse control
issues, no coercion issues. And I think
we're seeing that now is that people are
being made to do something
when they're coerced, they're bribed,
their impulse control's down, it was an
impulse buy, Yeah. right? We'll give you
a free donut.
I think that's just how the internet is.
for a year.
advertising and everything is just like
exploiting you where you're at and it's
like you look at these internet cafes in
Asia, you know, where people are
spending 16, 18 hours a day there. They
can't even feed their kids. They have,
you know, their their personal life is
in shambles and they're sitting in a
chair all day long because they cannot
unplug from this thing. So you can
imagine what the health complications,
I'm sure, that are coming from that
situation. And then it's like, yeah,
then you're then you're you know,
throwing at them these life decisions.
Now, I think we should reach people
wherever they're at. So I'm I'm I'm on
the fence of of exactly how to do that.
I could just see that this metaverse
thing is is going to put people in a
very bad situation.
How do we reach them with the gospel and
how do we, you know, win them over?
I think we can. I think we can use it,
but we have to understand
the nature
of it is addiction.
Right? Because the concept is you and I
can't even stop doing this. Like I have
a rule when we're going to we're going
to actually go out to lunch everybody,
so you know, I The original invitation
was, "Hey, I'll take you guys out to
lunch." Actually, I think I contacted
Scotty first and I said, "Oh, you know,
what they say in kindergarten, if you
bring something for everybody, you got
to invite everybody." But then Keith is
the more conscientious one here in this
group, I can tell. And he said, "Wait a
minute, are you sure you want to take
out
eight or nine of our staff?" You
remember saying that?
So you actually believe in full
disclosure. Yeah. You believe in, you
know, making a informed consent, right?
Versus me, "Hey, I'll take your whole
staff out to eat. Ah, there's 47 staff
now. Hey, Tim, we're glad you did that,
right?"
Exactly, so that's the whole concept is
you already, just based on your
personality since you are very
conscientious, I can tell. I could tell
that even before I met you, like I met
you on the shows, is that you're wanting
things to be exact, precise, etc.
That whole concept,
right? Where does that happen? Where
where are the lines blurred
there? And I think that you're right, we
should, you know, engage them wherever,
but just understand the nature of this
is they have designed everything about
this for addiction.
Right? Have you noticed when you
refresh, what do you do? You pull. Does
that remind you of anything?
Well, of course, of course. They they've
designed
I have to check. This is Pavlov's dog.
Like we're experiencing Pavlov's dog
every moment. And I'll be honest with
you, all my friends that we go out with,
I mean, we're committed, right?
But I'm going to have a rule today. And
you know what that rule's going to be?
No, if if you touch it, Yeah.
That's my rule, my standing rule for all
my friends. And we'll try to do stuff
like, "Hey, Brittany,
I think you were getting a ride to the
airport. Did you put a post on that? Did
anyone Do you need a ride? Did you get
one already?" Nice try, right? Some of
my friends aren't so conscientious as
you. They will use manipulation to get
out of paying for the meal. So I have I
have a question then. If we know
cuz I don't know if you guys have seen
Black Mirror.
No. It's kind of like meta It's a crazy
show that came out, I want to say in the
last 5 years. It's very technological.
It taught It has VR, virtual reality.
It's very based in like a metaverse type
of world. Um and it's about It's
basically about the negative effects of
technology. And so if we already know,
especially from research with social
media, if we already know the harmful
effects
of the of like what the metaverse could
be and technology in general, why do we
still pursue it? Like the True. But like
does the benefits outweigh
the cons? You know, does the pro
outweigh the cons? Because sure you can
get people to exercise, but they still
have to cater to people who don't want
to exercise.
and ultimately, would it be better for
us to create a show,
right, discussing different issues?
Probably it would be more effective cuz
we'd have music, we'd have a plot, we'd
have characters, right? And we'd assign
one character to be the one, "No, you've
got to do good for people no matter
what." And we'd have another character
and say, "No, the ends don't justify the
means, right?" We'd create kind of some
little tension between you guys cuz
that's what we have to do, right? To
create a good show. I mean, you
understand that being in Hollywood doing
script design and stuff like that is
that but that's the question is would
using that media itself of acting, and
that's I think what you really have your
forte in, is that you argue that the the
media itself of acting with the muses,
with the actual entering into the role
of that person
where you're having actors channeling
dead spirits. Like literally Sasha
Fierce, right? Who's Sasha Fierce? Well,
Sasha Fierce is who she becomes like
Beyonce becomes when she's going to
really kick it. And she even honestly
said she's like, "Yeah, she's a lot more
liberal than I am. Like I'm kind of shy
as just a person, but she enters into
another persona."
Right? I think she's becoming less shy
because she's being broken down by Sasha
Fierce. That's the whole thing. So, I
think that's the concept is is the media
itself
problematic. Is the way it's done
itself.
That's an interesting idea that that
there are a lot of celebrities that do
have these sort of alternate
personalities.
And that's kind of what the metaverse is
offering you as a general populace, you
know, it's like they've kind of done
this with the elite. Now they're like
turning this over to the common person
and you can become multiple people and
have you know multiple things.
That's the concept is that you can be
whoever you want to be regardless of
actual anatomy, actual physiology,
actually a hormone profiles, genetic
profiles. And that's ultimately what
we're wanting is we're not happy being
us.
Right? But that's because we're lacking
God in our hearts.
So, we figure if I get the sex change
I'll be happy. If I make a million
dollars I'll be happy. If I am actually
in this relationship
I'll be happy. Like I was telling Mikey,
there was a guy in Japan that married a
character from a video game.
You know, and so that's the thing is
that we have a God-shaped hole in our
heart.
Right? And we're looking to fill that in
any way possible, in anything that
promises it. And the metaverse promises
you can be whatever you want to be.
You can do whatever you want to do. And
that's really the same lie that the
media tells you too. Like Magic Kingdom,
that was another incident, right? I can
do whatever I want. I can be whoever I
want.
It's the same lies in the garden. Yeah.
You will be like gods. Right? What's to
prevent you from you know being that god
in the metaverse?
You can even create your own worlds and
you have so many enough followers you
probably are kind of a god.
Make everyone subservient to you. Yeah,
that's just really crazy. I think
something that I find really
interesting, I think that you two
mentioned um
it's funny how
our brains can't tell the difference
between reality and virtual reality, but
yet with touch our brains can tell the
difference between like an actual
physical touch of a person, but not a
virtual one. And that's and that's I
think the whole concept is that you have
to understand that I'm going to go
someplace that may be a little
uncomfortable for you guys is that
people feel like
um
Have you heard of auras? Like people
talk about auras. 100% new age. But
there's an exception to that. Is that we
are actually each surrounded by an
atmosphere. An atmosphere that can be
charged and influenced by goodness,
courage, strength, honesty, integrity,
or it can be surrounded by that miasma
of unconfessed sin.
Of fear, of cowardice, of hatred, right?
And so it does actually affect us. Guys,
when you have Have you ever noticed some
people like
that just animals don't like them.
Right? I mean they just go after them.
And other people are like the the dog
just comes over and starts licking them.
It's like, "Wait a minute. Bring me Are
you the dog whisperer? What's going on?"
But those are actual neurochemical
and possibly even electromagnetic
things that are changing. They found
that when people are afraid of animals
they secrete a small amount of copper on
their skin and the animal picks up on it
immediately, right? And then if you the
animal knows you're afraid of it
that's the issue. They also have found
that some of the animals may also be
able to pick up on the the amino acids
cysteine and methionine are more common
in meat. So, they can sense if you're a
meat eater
or not, right? And the thing is is if
they can pick up on those things
how are those going to influence us? I
mean right now
you are surrounded by a cloud.
And they've proven that. They've
actually had women do specific sensitive
hormonal assays and they're doing it
under a hood, full gear, full PPE, the
whole nine yards, and they kept getting
you know, bad results for this estrogen
assay.
And they finally replaced
this girl cuz it was so they figured she
wasn't coming. They replaced with a guy.
They're like, "Ah, see, it's great." And
then they got this even more qualified
girl who was like even better. And then
she did it and they threw it off because
you're surrounded by a cloud of
estrogen. So, how how about
women who live together. You know why
they cycle together?
sync. Yeah.
Cuz you're surrounded by a cloud. And
that cloud influences
them around you. And that's that's the
concept is that I can't send my cloud
through the metaverse.
Right? I can't send you whatever it is
that's surrounding me and influence you.
And this is a huge cutting edge area of
research. They're trying to figure out
what it is, right? That is producing
these things. And the theory is
is that it's a hormonal thing. Cuz just
as estrogen can create a cloud around
you strong enough to influence the women
to start cycling with you
is the endorphin that flows through me
strong enough to now cheer you up,
right? Is the positive hormonal sort of
experience that comes from serving God,
satisfaction, right?
Peace. Yes, exactly. And and and even
non-Christian cultures recognize this.
Ikigai is having purpose in your life,
right? Have you ever noticed if you meet
somebody who has purpose in their life,
they're like, "Whoa, this this guy is
inspiring. I want to go out and do
something now." Well, why do you want to
do that, right? Is because you've been
influenced. And it's not the same as
when you watch someone right? And it's
not just the fact they're finding of
let's replicate everything to be exactly
the same. They can't produce it. They
can't produce it in these orphans. The
orphans didn't grow, right? They needed
something
that was different. And and I believe
personally
it's not just um
the
you know, concept of oh, this person is
my my brother, right? I have a
relationship with them. Cuz the Berlin
Aging Study show that when you have an
aged individual in your home, right?
They live longer. But hopefully that's
not rocket science, right? You're caring
with them. They're surrounded by young
people, right? They're draining to us,
right? Cuz they everyone thinks about
that. Oh, my my mother is such a burden.
I had my grandmother in my home for
almost 14 years. She lived to 94 and she
was supposed to die at like literally
85. She had a stroke. She was completely
paralyzed. Couldn't move.
Had to be turned every 2 hours and she
kept living.
And the reason why I believe she kept
living was not just that I turned her
every 2 hours. I didn't give her Ensure,
but I gave her like vegan organic
blended avocados. Everything went in
that G-tube and I did all the medical
stuff possible. But the Berlin Aging
Study has shown, proven that not only is
that older person going to live longer,
every person in the household is going
to live longer. Oh, interesting. And
then they tried to say cuz of course the
Berlin Health Study is published in the
Journal of Human Evolution. Right? So,
they tried to say it's cuz of the
genome. You know, cuz it's your
relatives, right? You're going to pass
on a genome. But then they crunched some
other numbers and they found that the
non-related caregiver also lived longer.
Wow. So, it's the act of doing
unselfishness. It's the act of doing
kindness. It's the act of helping the
weak, right? Because our understanding
in Christianity is the strong are to
bear the weak, right? Whereas evolution
is the survival of the fittest,
right? Hey, get rid of the dead weight.
Hey, that person in that nursing home,
get rid of them. To us as Christians,
those people in nursing homes are the
exact people that I'm going to go visit.
And what they've shown is when you care
for those people to the point of having
them in such close proximity as your
home, it enhances not only their
quantity and quality of life but it
somehow empowers you to live longer.
As a young person, what's going on
there? And I believe that we're all
surrounded by this atmosphere and it's
influenced by not only our decisions
that we make, but the thoughts that
we're thinking
the principles that we cherish, right?
Everything around you influences people.
I mean we don't understand how powerful
and quick it is. People make a decision
about you in 7 seconds. Did you know
that? How do they make that decision so
fast? Right? I believe that it's
something, right? Around you.
It's a visual input. It's a maybe audio
perhaps. But in 7 seconds you're not
getting much visual. You're not getting
much audio, right? What are you making
that decision based on? I think these
are things that
are not quite understood yet. So, my
argument is going to be yes, we should
try to influence people in whatever way
we can, but it's never ever a
replacement for this.
Yeah. Sounds like you're living in the
real world, man.
That's right.
Well, thank you so much for coming on to
the show and sharing your expertise and
you know your perspective. And I hope
this has been a
a good discussion for you guys to
participate in with us. We hope that you
have gained some insight into the human
body, into the mind, into the
scriptures, and that you can make you
know, informed decision because that's
what we talked about. It's about
informed consent whatever you're going
to do. And remember that whatever it is
that you're going to do, you should do
it to the glory of God. So, we thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
next time and we just hope that you have
a happy Friday. Take care.
Is there any hope for me? What can I do
to unify my family on not watching
harmful media? How do I know my thoughts
are my own and how can I distinguish
between impressions from God? I'm
nervous when it comes to sharing my
testimony. It is really that important.
I stopped watching mainstream media. Now
what? Sometimes we get a lot of people
asking the same kind of questions, so we
thought it would be cool to make these
little videos answering some of them
in a new series called I got a question.
Concise answers to your media related
questions.
We'd love to hear from you. Reach out to
us privately on our Instagram page or
our Facebook.
And if you don't use social media,
that's all right. Send us an email
through our website
littlelightstudios.tv/contactus.
Hey,
we're here to help.
We're here to help you let your little
light shine.